hello enter welcome to this video
playing unti unti lotto finland Kings
Indian okie dokie arrive by
transposition I'll see five cents mm-hmm
while it's normally quite happy to see
the center closed okay taking
immediately or it's not not clear what
the most precise move what is so let's
play one rope cheap one and five is a
very risky move in this position very
risky and I was the first time that he
actually starts to think and the
position might already be toast as 96
comes Queen age 5 comes okay so giving
the exchange yeah maybe just print you
fire keep it simple get on the G file
possible Queen trade queen is 6 all
right let's know then we don't need to
trade Quincy already let's cancel that's
castle and try to try to make this yeah
play play for the attack swallow try the
same there's a second night coming
around and look here look here we have
three is also interesting have three
yeah okay three is pretty strong h phi h
four maybe h5 maybe h5 is stellar still
the move okay let's just protect this
for the moment and not rush things just
be should be seven now or h4 h4 h5 it's
really a bit annoying without Queen at
five okay and this is this is quite
strong
so on Bishop e7 or let's just protect
this stuff it's not exactly he doesn't
have many active ideas
so no age 5 or that's something quicker
yeah it should be okay Knight f6 196
only has one check 182 so I'll take
their
check okay wait if I go there it to us
it was actually threatening something
and it still shouldn't work right okay
298 I simply don't see it check King a
for there is nothing happening there I'm
losing this game I quitting chess really
thanking me live rosanna follow chicks
f5 is really tattoo tattoo much here we
add this up it's an old story but yeah
after 10 seconds span blacks position is
pretty much toast I just not take a
little bit of time and evaluate this
because you can basically stop here 95
is 6 it's killing just kidding a 95 and
snow even had this yeah no it's just a
matter of not blundering stuff Thank I
didn't blunder anything check yeah just
just take this it's basically after f5
it's it's it's basically can't I'll show
you black cam just is too far to wiki on
the light squares and his King position
c5 is already questionable but here if
you play a new 97 or whatever you can
try to hang around with that with a
passive position but not a position that
gets killed quickly with f5 is just
opening digging your own grave in some
way okay well thanks for watching